you yourself actually have someone that
you uh
choose your battles to
uh tap into some wisdom are you gonna
let me name drop here uh yeah yes do it
go for it are you talking about my good
friend and mentor dwayne the rock
johnson
oh yes yes i am and i am such a fan of
his i am fangirling out i would love to
know one piece of dwayne the rock
johnson advice because i really respect
him oh
you know what he's given me a lot of
great advice in my career at moments i
really needed it whether it was changing
my moniker online from
an alias to lily whether it was deciding
to the late night show i actually asked
him for advice um and i'll give you the
advice he gave me then because i had
called him and i had said i'm really
nervous about this opportunity i don't
know if i should do it i was on the
fence and i said i don't want to be
pigeonholed as a host now as someone who
just is gonna be behind a desk you know
i have aspirations to act and write and
he said to me
if you were gonna be pigeonholed you
would have already been pigeonholed as
the youtube girl and you never let that
happen
and so i was like okay yes sir
i love that
i love that um okay well uh last but not
least at the my
i have dark circles under my eyes and i
let my girls go to bed way too late
because we were up watching the bad guys
did you like it this is such a good film
with like sam rockwell and aquafina and
mark mcmahon mark maron
and
lily singh a stellar cast
and it's just a really good script it's
getting very well reviewed
um y'all it's bomb it's
it's actually really when i watched it
for the first time i was
sh i knew it would be good but i was
laughing out loud it was hysterical this
is a great movie um and
may we all find our shape
in the right formation and remember that
when we go like this that we can get
ourselves back to this yes thank you
her new book be a triangle is out now
and the bad guys is premiering april
22nd my dear friend lily singh i admire
you so much please keep speaking the
wisdom please keep making us laugh and
please keep doing everything that you
see fit to do we'll all follow
[Applause]
[Music]
you